Moe Moe boo!
Boe Boe Boo!
Go shirt and majo Sama!
Hi everybody, hi!
Hello, hello, hello Hello hello hello hello Moe Moe Boe!
Moe Moe Moe, moe Moe Moe, Moe, Moe Moe energy, Moe Moe Under
time Moe Moe Moe Moe
Happy Friday!
Yes!
MGS Cat Furniture Final!
Thank you!
The boxes are so cute, aren't they?
Oh my gosh.
If you didn't see Konami release some like Metal Gear Cat
scratch boxes, and they're so cute.
I kind of wish though!
I know that they're theming it around the Master Collection.
Volume 2.
But I wish they had one that was the orange.
Oh, hi-yo!
Oh, hi-yo-gozai-mas!
I forgot to meet you too!
Happy Friday, looking forward to paling around.
We're just gonna be paling around today, guys.
Moe, curly, Larry.
No.
And that's...
His name is not even Moe.
His name is Moe.
The Minky Pal hour.
So true.
Cats do love to play as snakes.
Do they?
I like my box.
I got from MGS 2.
MGS Con 2.
And the matching mug.
Oh, I got that same one too.
I think I know exactly which one you're talking about.
Yeah.
Con Minter.
one that they just released that's like on the Konami store
right now that is it's it's like kind of themed after like a
Metal Gear box but it says like MG like Metal Gear Solid
Master Collection Volume 2 and I'm like okay well it's cute
but it's like kind of just an advertisement and then they
have and then they have uh what was it they have oh then
there's gonna be a cat convention in october i believe and
they're going to have ones of like they're gonna have a
barrel that's not it's not a box but it's like a card a
cardboard scratch barrel from like the barrels that you can
get into in mgs4 and then they have the love box from Peace
Walker.
So I'm like, okay, but I have to get the love box.
That's the best thing.
That's like, that's really good.
And it kind of matches my cafe aesthetic because it's pink
actually.
It's actually pink.
Yes, yes, yes.
It makes me think, oh my gosh, I want to put out like Minto.
cat merch and I was like what if I did like a minto on a
stream like a fuzzy minto on a stream a barrel is just a
round box so true so true real and true this time real and
true always
off topic we're watching aew and seeing minto is all Let's
go!
It was so funny.
Oh my gosh.
Hamburger Kun went to the wrestling match and brought Minto
plushie and then I was on the telly.
Yeah, Oshikant's on the telly!
I'm told that your cat merch would be greatly appreciated,
but I need to.
of them oh you was telling you this huh let's capture some
pals we need them do it do we need pals do we need friends
forced friendship is still friendship right sometimes
sometimes when i play games like this i feel like do you
guys remember that twilight zone episode of like the little
kid that had like the crazy powers and can turn people into
like jack-in-the-boxes and stuff and Everybody, like, tried
to appease him.
But...
But if you didn't listen to him, he would turn you into a
jack-in-the-box.
He would just essentially kill you.
Hi, Tosco!
Hello, my wife!
I saw that the, uh, Denso2 Patreon stuff.
Yeah, but they just posted it!
I remember the Simpsons version.
Yeah, Tosco featured artist you're a real fine gal minto
don't turn me into a box i don't have that power but i
sometimes feel like when i'm capturing the pals and forcing
them to be my friend like at least in pokemon they're kind
of like yeah you gotta catch them all not to become your pal
they're your pokemon but in this game they're like no you
they're your pals they're your friends you know I would 100%
buy Minto cat merch for my kitty.
Yeah?
Just receive my Minto happy.
Yippee!
Thanks for getting it, Jay!
Thank you!
Minto, you should be careful with Steiner's Manechan
announcement.
I think he might be forming his own villain group to take on
Densets.
That's like AKB48 existed.
And then they have sister groups like SKE48 and NMB48.
They're different parts of Japan.
But then they were like, let's spice things up.
And they're like, we're going to make a rival group called
Nogizaka 46 instead of AKB 48.
And then it's made by the same guy.
So it's like, oh, wow.
Oh, the rivals.
Oh, if I support this group, I'm feeding the pockets of
them.
I'm feeding the pockets of the same man.
Steiner Emmerich.
What does that even mean?
Sakura Zaka and Hinata Zaka were my faves.
But yeah, rivals, quote unquote, right?
Idols in wrestling truly are indistinguishable.
It's so true, actually, though.
Like, when people say, well, I guess it's also people say
that about V-Tubers.
Like, V-Tubers in wrestling is very similar.
I think a lot of people could get along.
like a lot of wrestlers and vtubers can get along in that
regard actually i went to an idol show once and a lot of
idols are also into wrestling in japan and um the idol she
brought out a wrestler and like interviewed him and it was
very very interesting i was like i mean some of the things i
couldn't understand because they were talking in like
wrestling terms in japanese so i was like
But it was really interesting.
Just hope he doesn't pull a Huey on you.
Oh, you should be on this boat.
No.
She only says that because she wants to see her idols just
as wrestlers.
Look, there is!
There are...
There's like the Japanese...
What is it?
The Josie Pro League or something.
It's like...
Is it J...
I don't know.
But there's like a girls league.
TJPW.
And they are also idols.
Yes, yes, yes.
Is Minto a face or a heel?
Are you asking where I attack?
Or with what do I attack?
With.
Because I want to attack with my mouth.
Heal for sure.
What does that mean?
Teach me, teach me.
I don't know.
Good or bad?
Oh, hero or bad guy?
Wait, so everybody's saying I'm a bad guy?
I'm the bad guy.
Meow.
Either you play your character straight or backstab them.
What?
You guys think I would backstab?
Nah, you're very villain-coded affectionate.
I'm a... I'm a...
I'm a hero of Hakiba!
What do you mean?
No!
Wait a second!
Is there a third option for neutral freaky?
I think I...
I'm a...
I feel like a switch.
You know, like I'm...
I'm...
It depends on the situation, maybe.
For sure, front stack.
Because it's easy and does a lot of damage.
That would make you a heal.
Dang, okay.
Nintendo Switch.
That was the Switch, you know, the Switch sound.
That's it.
Oh, vowing to take Akiba is pretty villainous.
Hey, wait, you know, we're villains now, but I mean, we're
heroes now, but test us.
Keep testing us.
We might have a villain arc.
I already feel more evil as we get closer to Halloween.
Not the Freudian slip now!
Oh my gosh, speaking of Halloween though, I am so ready for
fall.
I, today I got, um, I got, uh, new, new, like, I had some
air fresheners before in my last, uh, made cafe, and then I
ran out of them, but I've decided to reorder new ones,
because I, from the same store, because, uh, their stuff is
so good, like, it lasted a very long time, one time I was in
a drive-through, and someone was like, your car smells so
good.
so yummy it smells so good and i was like i've never gotten
this compliment before sir you're a hero you came across a
harmless guy wearing a mask waiting for his friends no he
was no he was causing trouble he was causing trouble
then they ate it can't believe your car got sniffed i know
but it's but i got them they're great for your I got some
and there's one is some mores and one is a pumpkin patch so
right now my maid cafe smells like so good it smells so
freaking good does Disney Pixar's cars trilogy ever make a
car freshener equals perfume cologne joke I don't know I
don't I don't remember when in the first movie that's the
only one I've watched But yeah, I have a candle that smells
like apple sheath cake.
Oh, I'm trying to be good and avoiding my local ice cream
place for their new September flavors.
Because I know they're gonna be good.
I know everything is already starting the fall flavors.
And I'm like, no, I can't.
No, I can't do it.
I can't.
I can't do it.
I gotta be good.
But you gotta support your local shops.
Don't guilt me.
I do.
Actually, I did.
I did so much.
That...
I...
That's why I'm working out way more.
They were so good!
But They were so good
It's okay though I've been doing so much dancing Lately I've
been doing a lot of dancing So Maybe it's fine to have a
little bit as a treat Because it balances out Right?
Yeah, I'm getting buff.
I'm getting buff.
It's fine.
Tempta!
Thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you.
Nothing wrong with the tree?
Yeah.
Yeah, I need the fuel to dance.
I don't think, though, that sugar is a good fuel for
dancing, probably.
Protein maxing.
Oh, yeah, I got that protein.
Everything.
protein in it right now i've seen though that some things
are starting to switch to like fiber which is kind of also
terrifying to think about like i've seen like fiber gummies
and stuff
meito 4.0 will be ripped in seven feet tall how do you know
that i'm not already huh fiber internet oh if only if only i
had that was fiber terrifying because they make okay say
they make a great a snack that is really really delicious
you don't look say you know some people don't look at like
the serving sizes and things like that um so say you like
pour yourself a bowl of whatever snack it is and then it's
at oops I just ate three times the serving amount and the
amount of fiber that I've been with the fiber That's me.
I don't look then be careful if you get fiber things because
that fiber stuff is gonna Hit you like a dang brick in your
tum tum.
Yeah Protein soda coffee was where I drew the line.
I'm so confused where the protein trend came from I'm
confused where all the suddenly I looked around and there
was like protein popcorn and protein protein cheese and I'm
like what was happening where is everything protein there
was a there was like some anime what was it where there was
a character that would just go protein what was it I can't
remember for the gains I'm always on that grind set baby was
it a gretzko oh the caring guru and a gretzko it must have
been that yeah yeah yeah sweet home i did read sweet home
but the web tune but i only watched like i think one or two
episodes of the of like the live action It's due to GLP-1s.
High proteins is needed to maintain muscle mass if someone
is on them.
I see.
Oh.
Aren't you confusing it with Persona 3 and Akihiko?
Well, I've never played Persona 3, so unless someone
programmed those memories into my mind, then I don't know.
The Netflix adaptation goes off the rails so fast.
Does it?
I remember enjoying it.
Have you played Persona games?
I played like a minuscule amount of four because it was lent
to me from a friend.
But I did not play so much.
Netflix adaptation was good for season one.
Fell off after though.
Aw, mean.
Season two and three are just fanfic.
What the heck?
Sometimes I don't mind.
It's hard to say.
Sometimes, you know, when like, okay, I don't mind a
one-to-one adaptation when it's something like, you know,
manga to anime.
When it's from a medium that doesn't move to medium that
moves, then doing one-to-one adaptation makes sense.
You know what I mean?
Like, Webtoon to live action or Webtoon to anime.
It makes sense.
Because now you're seeing all the characters like move
around, and wiggle and it's fun but like the the whole leg i
don't i don't know metal gear solid live action it will
never happen it will never happen i do love a silly wiggler
do Why bother if you aren't going to make something of it?
I don't think it's...
Well, I mean the story.
I mean, I think there's art in, like, the shots you direct
and things like that.
Unless it's, like, a very impactful, like, manga panel that
people are wanting to see in motion, then it makes sense to
kind of animate that similarly.
But you can always change other shots and stuff.
I don't know But then It's so funny because like They'll
make Like Disney live actions Have been Like some of them
have been A little different Than the movies that they're
Adapting Take Cinderella for example People really liked
that And then you have some of the other Like adaptations
that people are like Oh, they changed too much.
And then you have the most recent Moana one where they
didn't change anything.
And people are like, oh, they didn't change anything.
I don't like the Disney live-action, though, for the most
part.
I'll just say that.
Movies make it hard to include a lot of plot in such a short
amount of time.
Yeah, that can be.
That's true, too, right?
I only saw clips of the Moana one.
on and it looks so bad it's it's it's like i feel like was
there even a director it's embarrassingly bad it's it's it's
it might be actually like the most soulless like remake
adaptation i've ever seen and i watched a bufasa oh it's no
way that was directed at all like she will just sing and and
have her arms at her side.
And I'm like, give me a little oof.
Give me a step.
Give me an arm raise.
Give me anything.
Beretta.
I always wanted to Beretta.
One problem is that animation and live action are
fundamentally different visual mediums that have different
strengths and weaknesses than each other.
Personally, I prefer animation.
Then there, that's totally valid.
There will always be You know, and there's always like the
thing that it's like if you don't care to watch the live
action, you don't have to.
You know?
So, hmm.
Can't move too much or they can't.
SFX the background.
Is that why?
Oh my gosh, wait, that's so infuriating.
Yeah, I don't know.
But I think that Metal Gear does not need an any movie
adaptation.
It is perfect as it is.
If they make one, though, I'd still watch it.
But I would be quite critical.
I would be like...
Dream Chaser!
Thank you so much for the gift, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
I would be very critical.
very critical indeed oh hi y'all I just think like Metal
Gear is already a movie enough so but I'm also I mean I was
gonna say I'm under the I'm under the like how do you say
the impression that you know things can be released as
multiple medias because you know not everybody can play a
game but then That's why we have Let's Play sometimes, too.
Oh, my gosh!
I was watching somebody...
Okay, there's this game series called The Sinking City.
And I was watching a YouTuber I like.
I was watching her playthrough of DLC.
And then there was a cutscene in it that was...
I saw it and I was like, oh, my gosh, this is just like
Control.
Because it had like...
like silhouette and then like close up face and then like
uh, like body like cut scenes that they had.
And then, and then my, my streamer she goes, she goes, wow,
this looks just like control.
And I was like, I got this reference.
Was it Gab smolders?
How did you know?
Stop.
I'm I'm, I'm holding up a knife to your neck right now.
How did you know?
How did How did you know?
Wait, was it really Gab?
Yes!
It was Gab!
You've mentioned Gab before.
Yeah, but I'm...
Okay, maybe I only watched like three people.
I know
you like them, Dutch.
That's so messed up.
She's so cozy.
I love her stuff.
Bad.
And I watched her before she was with Jacksepticeye.
I don't even know if they're still together.
But I watched her before she was with the big leagues.
Funny.
Funny, funny.
The VTuber follows the same YouTubers I follow.
what a time to be alive i'm just like you guys i'm just like
you guys before it was cool yeah before it was cool i saw
her control gameplay actually i i went to watch it i i
didn't realize she played it hey i mean i hope you're doing
wonderfully you too brandon i hope you're feeling great
she's one of us collab win no way Sometimes I like watching
people completely detached from VTubers, you know, because I
can then just sit back and watch as, like, a fan and not
have to be, like, thinking of anything else.
So, obviously, I do watch, like, you know, my friends'
streams as well and things like that, or I try to.
Like, if it's a VTuber or something, I, part of me, there's,
like, a couple VTubers I watch that, like, I try to, like,
watch from, you know, I go back in my mind palace, and I
was, like, back in 2019, before I was a VTuber, when I was
still just watching VTubers as a fan, go back to that
moment.
But, yeah, I don't know, it's good to have, like, your own
things that you like to watch, and do.
that has nothing to do with work.
So, which is so funny because my work is playing video games
and being dumb online.
I watched a live adaptation from Me to You.
Oh, of From Me to You, Kimi Nito-doke.
It's really good and seemed pretty faithful to the source.
I recommend it.
It's on Netflix.
Oh, that's, see, like, I feel like slice of life are very
easy to, or like, those kind of, like, Shoujo manga and
things like that are pretty easy to adapt.
when they're, like, day-to-day life and things like that,
yeah.
Entertainment is valid work.
I don't know.
I never feel like it at all at all, but...
Hey, we have fun here.
We have fun, and let's have fun playing the powers.
I did my allotted 30 minutes of yapp.
And we can keep yapping while in game, too.
as we do as we do
like Naruto what I'm failing to see the connection
entertainment is important work too I guess it's because
like I agree with you don't get me wrong I agree
entertainment the arts you know are so important music
connects the world right but in my head I cannot rank myself
amongst, you know, amongst those people.
Like, yeah.
But no, I agree.
I agree.
There's never enough yapping.
Yappa, yappa, yappa, yappa, yappa.
And performing on stage and producing wonderful music.
I try.
I don't know.
My confidence in my singing lately has not been...
Hmm.
Like, I'm...
I've been wanting to go to singing lessons for years now.
I don't know.
I feel like stuck in a rut.
So, I don't know.
Karaoke stream wind.
No!
I think that will make me feel worse.
I don't mean to say it to be like...
Oh, I'm so sad.
Please.
Send me in.
comments about my voice but it is also like why I don't do
so many karaoke streams so often the most important
entertainer in my life what that's crazy thank you though I
just I just feel like I I think a lot of singers probably
feel this too is like you try you sing a song and like I
wish my voice was better suited for more songs if that makes
sense like I I hear a song and I'm like oh this is is such a
great song to sing it's so cool or something so cute or
things like that and then I'm just like ah I try singing it
and it doesn't sound right so hmm yeah incredibly real yeah
I think a lot of people think so that's where I've been
feeling not so confident with everything lately but you know
I guess if I were to get a voice lessons I want I'm maybe I
could like search for something in my made cafe aerial don't
worry I was going to send those comments anyway thank you
Brandon thank you hmm that makes sense there's a lot of
techniques and ranges to learn yeah yeah yeah Vicky takes
lessons all the time it seems yeah and she's learning from
like a pro like a real real pro like like a legend it's very
cool so yeah okay join join join
but yeah i don't know we'll see if i have any singing things
in the future Oh my gosh.
If I have any singing things in the future, be kind.
Don't be too critical of me.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
YouTuber who is amazing.
It has imposter syndrome.
More dynamic duo.
Oh man.
I'm a statistic.
Thank you so much for the hug.
Thank you.
Okay.
Am I heavy?
why do i feel like i'm not moving so fast all right so we
are at level 40 baby hags are in demand we are buff still in
awesome um somebody just ran into me uh i don't think i i oh
where's that guy going oh he's gathering i feel like not a
lot of people are still sloppy server and um i don't know
how many other sloppies and friends are uh playing
uh oh that's not what i meant to do trying to run but it's
minto server i fear i mean that's okay You know, maybe,
maybe, I don't want to say like, oh, I'm going to stop
playing because, you know, I did want to play with everybody
and have it all be, you know, one thing, one thing that's
fun about playing with friends is hopping on the server and
seeing what new things are online and all.
You might have already answered this, but did you do a pal,
an ability tier list or any other tier lists?
and I have not but I did see that um that they put out like
a thing they they put out like a let's rank the our pals our
favorite pals and I put meow cat is number one for mine it's
pronounced it's I can make that joke Wait, it's burned out,
so I can make that joke because I'm autistic.
Aw, man.
Everybody keeps diagnosing me recently.
Let's us.
We can send a guy out.
Um.
I don't know.
Does this have, like, a level?
Oh.
We're gonna send out you.
You.
I don't know.
I don't know who you are.
Pals to Dispen.
auto assign oh wow that's alive why is it sending out so
many people why is it sending out so many pals okay I don't
know what's happening wait change
destination ed ability and smash ability tier list with to
the key maybe more pals more rewards okay we'll send it them
reward reward is a hundred and twenty nine percent okay go
Ah, oh, there they go!
Onwards, my pals!
Bring great spoils for our homeland!
Onwards!
Not diagnosed, but I'm pretty sure I love Minto.
What's the heck?
Thank you for using them.
Goodbye, my pals!
Goodbye!
Wait, how do I emote in this game again?
F?
Uh...
Hey!
Who are you?
Pal Recruiter.
Oh, Flambel!
I'll take you.
I'm not gonna speak for everyone, but I don't care who else
plays this game.
Hell, I've never played this game, but I very much enjoy
watching you play this.
No way, really!
That means a lot.
Thank you.
My sweet!
Goodbye, my pals.
Speaking of rankings, the Toho popularity results came out
recently.
Koishi beat Marisa for first place by only two points.
Oh my gosh, Koishi.
Koishi resurgence.
Why?
Also, new, I want to play the new look at this guy.
So See ya!
He's so slow.
Everybody's running past him.
I want to play the new embodiment of Scarlet Devil.
That comes out next week!
Yeah, the new Toho.
The new not new Toho.
Oh wait, I'm not in the base anymore, I think.
Come on, come on back, Meowcat.
I'm more surprised that Marisha is still at the top even
years later.
Master Spark is powerful, you know?
new EOSD yes for PC yeah it's a remake oh the music is is
Zoon did like remastered the music and redid it and
everything it's crazy
it's so awesome what do we need for the upgrade sphere
assembly line 2 for that was it something that was like
refined ingots now did we have refined ingots.
How did I make these again?
Refined ingots.
We can make a lot of them.
Oh, awesome.
We have so much stuff!
I'm just gonna make like a ton of them.
There's also the Switch release for JP.
Oh, cool!
Hmm.
I'm glad Zune paid an artist to upscale his flawed art
rather than an AI upscale.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I do have it on my schedule for next week I believe
so we can do the let's see I do kind of want to continue the
the quest so maybe we just head into the fire we got our
torrentress before um I don't think I don't think wait
Lunaris was I able to capture them I can't remember his art
is so iconic I love it yeah it's like the original Higurashi
art you know it's so good so so good everybody's everybody's
oh my goodness everybody's gone yeah my little meow cats are
so cute um
I don't see him.
Maybe not.
It's in my party.
Oh, you are so...
You're so right.
Oh, that's right.
Because our party is now looking very blue.
Dabadi, dabba die.
I might have made that joke last week and I don't remember.
Just ignore.
Just pretend I didn't if I did.
There's also two guys here that I...
You did?
Okay.
Evergreen joke.
There's two guys that I have not caught yet, so we should
try and grab them.
We'll just kind of conquer...
This guy too, Univold.
I don't even think I've tried him yet.
Actually, yeah, because I was too low level.
And Anubis, not yet.
Elizabeth B, we'll go until like 45 maybe.
I don't know.
I feel like these guys are kind of tough.
So let's go try Elphadran.
Can't wait to hear it again next week.
I was saying earlier that I don't...
Was that the noise for somebody about to raid my base?
Oh.
Lucky
Where did that drop?
Oh, why did I do that?
Oh my god, that's embarrassing.
I'm going to do this.
Is it behind me?
Yeah, kill him.
There it is.
It landed in their base!
Boink.
I thought it was behind you.
No, I watched it fall.
Thank you.
Um, I was saying, though, is...
I don't know how more common I'll, like, make, like, regular
playing of the game.
As much as I like it, like I mentioned, it was, you know,
it's kind of like, oh...
My friends.
But I don't want to, like, drop it, obviously.
Like, that's not my intention, either.
But maybe just kind of, like, whenever I feel like it.
But it is Doki's server at the same time.
I kind of, like, play it because Doki is paying for it.
So I know she can just stop paying for it if people stop
playing it.
But at the same time...
Meowcat, you are not a logger.
Come on.
Yeah, so, I don't want her to be paying for it is what I
mean, and her, and nobody playing it.
But then she keeps paying for it because I'm playing it.
So it's maybe an endless cycle, but it's fine.
We are going to there.
Lucky drop, that was fun.
We got cold resistant armor schematic one.
Me too.
Yeah, maybe.
Oh!
Did I level up?
Let's go!
Um...
We'll do more health.
A little more health.
Tell Sloppies to get together and beat the game.
How?
I mean...
I guess if you only do the quest, then beating the game
could be pretty easy probably.
All right, Meowcat, we're gonna catch this guy.
So don't kill him, okay?
Stop logging.
Yeah, it's Doki for a copy of the world or start a new
spooky dark element pal only run.
There's a very mint-coated pal later on.
Another one!
Also, I want that dungeon over there.
All right, Meowcat, let's go.
Whoa, Meowcat doing big damage.
We're watching, we're observing.
We're a...
Wait.
I have one I called Mint.
No way!
Meowcat, be careful!
Call him back.
Oh, shoot.
Maybe now?
Come on.
I'll just keep going.
It's so low.
Maybe I should...
change the giga sphere.
Nah, we got this.
Yippee!
Yahoo!
Yeah, I could always ask her about that, though.
So that we could, uh, so that I could at least keep my save.
That is definitely an option.
I forgot about that, actually, so thank you.
Definitely, definitely, definitely an option.
And I'm gonna grab that ball right there.
Laying on the ground.
Probably from a dead trainer you can give meow cat mercy hit
with the surgery table so that they can't kill pals by
accident you wait did that just disappear no okay good i was
gonna say that would be so unfortunate if i just missed that
all right
everybody's asleep this is the perfect time to go
Everybody's asleep.
Little babies, little babies.
Did you just wake up?
No.
Not by me.
Had a nightmare or something.
He's drowning.
Is that a human?
Oh my god he's dead Oh my god he's dead
Okay we have two ways we can go I'm going this way first
He's fine he's fine The loop moon
I'm gonna Actually I can't tell like that way wait there's
so this this is this is a huge dungeon is this not a way
wait why is it lit up like it's a way i i don't know where
i'm going
yeah he's he's actually from that what was that show that
australian mermaid show h2o he turns into a mermaid when he
touches water this guy looks bored not dead just Sleeping
with the fishes!
I sneak 100.
Under the sea.
Darling, it's better.
Down where it's wetter.
This better be good.
Oh, it was fine.
H2O mention.
Chloe Norr!
That's where like the a lot of like the Norr jokes came from
with like Australian accents because a lot of Americans
watched H2O they would be like Chloe Norr!
So sorry if you're Australian and you feel attacked you can
blame the mermaids
I love the accent it's so cute I think so too I think it's
pretty cute
I'm people I don't think I have an accent but people say I
do have an accent so oh my to to make fun of somebody else's
accent they're winning when I apparently have oh what's
wrong what's wrong What's wrong?
Everyone has an accent?
I guess that's true.
Mostly from Jaguar.
Curses.
Curses applying to Jaguar.
That one, I don't even know.
Nobody else apparently says it like that except me, so...
So, I don't even know where that came from.
Everybody's asleep.
I'm going the right way, right?
I think so.
Oh.
You wink.
Grintail.
Wait, where am I going?
This way?
Alright, let's get to the...
Oh my gosh, this room is humongous.
I'm not sure if it's an accent, but the way you say words is
the best way of saying words.
I'm glad you think so.
Minto dialect.
It's just ghost.
Just think it's something you learn in the ghost world, you
know.
I do love me some Brooklyn Minto.
Sometimes I forget how to do accents.
And then like, oh it's this guy!
I feel like I have a million of them.
I have like a million of these guys because of...
Uh...
Because of fishing.
Hey.
You coming after me?
Look how cute Meowcat is, oh my god.
It's okay, Minto.
My mom once called it Jaguar.
We are.
My grandpa said Jaguar.
Whatever, it's adorable.
Wait a...
Do you like me?
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Is this the big guy?
Yeah.
We'll get the big one.
Ouch, uh, stop it.
Ouch!
Oh, oh, oh.
I'll get him.
I probably could bring his HP down a little bit more, but...
Yowcat, do your thing!
He would have loved you.
Oh, sorry, I was talking about the turtle.
But I probably would have liked your grandpa too.
Surely.
I think I would have liked your grandpa.
Stop being stubborn.
I know you like me.
Woo!
Cheeky bastard.
There we go.
We can leave.
all the other guys alone i mean they're dead anyway so it's
just a bit soon
let's do our yes and yes awesome what technology i have nine
ancient technology points that's good that's double jump
boots we could get those um all right let's leave
why would ghost not have cat ears i don't i've great
questing probably every ghost has cat ears flying pow win
i'm such a landlubber though erg i'm a landlubber um wait
this guy already respawned i thought it was like every hour
or something i did catch him that's weird funny jaguars were
my elementary school mascot and every morning intercom
message ended with principle saying have a great day jaguars
let's go see very common
uh very common pronunciation then if i were a there's the
point oh it's day night cycle oh gotcha gotcha gotcha oh i
was gonna say he he left we will teleport to the closer
thing and grab the other guy and then we shall traverse the
terrifying volcano lands
muffly sounds like miffy i want you
miffy miffy miffy miffy miffy I'm glad that Miffy is so
popular now.
Like, there's so much Miffy stuff everywhere.
It's great.
Jeremy Clarkson says, it's a jag.
Let's go to this guy.
Is that one of the Top Guns guys?
Not Top Gun.
Wait, what's that?
Oh my god.
Who's straight up jagwiring right now?
Top Gear!
Top gear, yes, yes, yes.
I was close.
My head was in the right...
My heart was in the right place.
It's been close enough.
Oh, we just need one more Miffy.
I saw one, didn't I?
You just... Oh, yes.
You think you can escape me?
Yeah, you think you can escape me?
Come here.
Come here, little Miffy.
It's okay.
This happens.
Surely it's fine.
It's so scary when the message comes up.
Oh my gosh.
8 p.m.
server restart.
I think it happens like every stream of mine.
Did he get away?
The one that got away.
Oh, here they come.
There he goes.
The one.
Oh,
he's stupid.
He doesn't know.
The one.
Come here.
Pretty sure to keep the game stable and restart.
Makes sense.
Yay.
Okay, where are we?
We are trying to get to this guy.
So I need to go...
Wait.
North?
Mint's place was in a heart.
I have no heart.
I saw Miffy's merch at a store near.
And I thought about buying it.
Miffy's just so cute.
Love Miffy.
Oh.
What do you do?
They're like having a picnic.
Okay.
They're like back to back.
that's so cute what's wrong with this guy why are you
excluding him from your thruple what's happening oh oh I did
I instinctually yeah okay I take care of them I loot this
nice thank you you're so cute
oh my meow cat oh my precious meow girl it's so Fuck yeah!
That's a...
God.
My precious, my precious.
All right, let's go get this guy.
The way he hugs me is so...
Oh, yeah, he's a weedle, weedle face.
He's a weedle, weedle face.
I'll get it next time I visit.
You don't have to, of course.
I just think...
I just think, uh...
Miffy, cute.
All right, Miao-ga.
Let's go.
Get him.
Big hit.
Oops.
Where is it?
Could be good.
Whoa!
First try!
Miao-Cat!
Look at you jumping!
We're jumping together!
Why are you jumping?
Is it because of me?
Wait.
Yay!
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy.
He's happy.
He's excited with that.
All skill, baby.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They jump when you jump.
Alrighty.
Alrighty, alrighty.
Now, we said we would hold off on Elizabeth.
And a new bush, I don't think we could do.
do Unibolt right now, but I don't know if we're gonna like
it.
So, we could also explore these lands.
Wait, didn't I?
Kelp Sea Hill.
I think I ended here last time.
I'll do anything but do the main quest, huh?
Also, do you remember you can ride the Spider Lady?
Oh, that's right.
Where is the statue?
a statue that one yeah whatever is fun so true it's gonna be
great when we go to something and we're like crazy
overpowered they're pretty good too okay I wonder if I I oh
wrong thing did I unlock her saddle here's the question I
got fengalope that's my guy right now I really like riding
fengalope though he's so airy
I am not sure if I'm able to get her yet
I can't be that far down hmm there's a search button you're
right but I can't remember her Wait, what's her name?
Tarantris.
Ah!
Level 20.
Okay, we got her.
Nice.
Thank you guys.
Let's go back home.
Neat.
Pal management.
Oh, I made them Engi.
Engi.
Where is she, anyway?
a rant oh no she's on a mission wait when do they get back
when do my pals come home from the war oh guys it's gonna be
a while it's gonna be a while hey did the indian stand at
the fair big mistake oh no indian food so yummy though
Oh, I thought it was, uh...
I thought it was the bar at the bottom.
The little, the white bar.
And I didn't see the one on the, uh, on the right.
So I thought I only saw the teeny tiny little point on the
left side there.
Okay, then it's almost done.
We can go do something else until then.
Let's see.
I mean, I can also, like, have him.
Let's go travel to...
Here.
Yeah, the circle's almost complete.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wasn't looking at the circle at first.
I was looking at the bar at the bottom, which is not real.
This is unexplored territory for me.
Chill it!
Let's go.
What is this over here?
We'll go to Eggie now.
Okay, come here.
Boing, boing, boing, boing, boing.
What are you?
what what is this anyway oh it's mystery pal let's go in
wait i'm actually curious though come on
oh it's a fox sparks okay okay some of these i feel like i
could probably do like off stream Like the really easy ones.
Hoi!
So I guess this is an area that you can...
Yeah, that you can spawn in.
Very, very interesting.
Blue...
Yeah, wait!
We could have blue...
Fox sparks.
But...
Tansy!
Is it still Fox?
Yeah, like an alternative starting zone.
Yeah, because everything's so easy here.
Oh.
It's sometimes hard for me to, like, remember that that's
kind of how this game works in a way, you know?
Because, you know, in so many games, if you, uh...
Hello?
Can I unlock?
Oh.
Wait, stop.
Sorry.
Let me unlock the fast.
travel there we go i was holding it down on accident and so
many games the further you go from your spawn point the
harder they get so chilly yeah it's like the ice version
okay so it is yeah pals have returned what what are we doing
why are you styling on me what's happening what's happening
my capture power oh i have to need five but my movement
speed If I enhance my pals.
I'll be movement speed.
Wow.
Oh, gosh.
She's so cool.
I don't usually get to catch you live.
I wanted to say hi and you're awesome from Australia.
Mintero.
Thank you.
Sorry that our time zones are like so bad.
I'm sorry.
But thank you for dropping by.
What are you buying?
What are you selling?
What's a mystic accessory?
A mysterious box whose interior synchronizes with the
owner's body.
Accessory equipment slots increased by one!
Wait, that would take all of my coins.
Hmm.
Your streaming time is usually around 9 a.m.
for us.
Oh yeah, I guess it's not so different from Japan, huh?
What if you have, like, work or something or school?
It could be tough.
I guess...
We're fine, maybe.
I don't need another accessory.
I'm cute enough with them.
With only one.
I don't know.
Whoa!
I've never seen the tree so close before.
Whoa.
Uh, open.
Bread.
Nice.
Give me that.
Oh.
Give me that for real.
Oh, we should probably go drop off our stuff, huh, too.
I don't say nar.
I say no.
And yeah, I'm at work at that time.
You don't say...
You're like, no, I must correct her.
I am not one of them.
I don't say nor.
I don't know.
Sometimes I've seen people say they're like, I don't say
nor.
But then they do.
They don't realize that they're saying nor.
You might be...
Oh, wow.
That guy took him out.
You might be in denial.
Whoa, what's going on?
on over here.
There's a fire.
Oh.
Hello.
It's just okay.
Why are they both here?
What are you doing?
I've got some great pals in stock!
Oh.
You've got some okay pals in stock.
He's a runner.
Yeah, Eggie, strike a pose.
Hmm.
Herbal?
Is it herbal or herbal?
Or bill?
Is it bill?
Everything is silent.
He lied.
Feed him to your pals.
I'll buy it.
I don't know if I have...
Oh, wait.
I think this might be my first herbal.
Yeah.
Yes, I actually have this that I would like to sell to you.
Oh, sell.
Wait, sell?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, sell it.
There we go.
Is there anything else that you take?
I don't think so.
What are you, what are you, what are you selling though?
That's insane.
Oh, the hat is cute, though.
The little gommos cap.
I like that.
Mmm.
Chicky peep poultry!
Chicky peep, chicky peep, chicky peep, peep, peep, peep!
Alright, come back.
Come, come, come, come.
We're gonna go explore this island over here.
Here I go.
Yeah, just a normal version.
Nothing special.
Chill it.
What do you...
You need to chill out down there.
Huh!
Isle of Murmurs.
Oh.
Ooh, there's some cute pals here.
Okay, very, very interesting.
Yes.
All right, we're going to go see what these two are.
And then there's also a thing.
This is where I have my base set up in my game.
Really?
Oh.
It's at the welcome home!
Wait, is this the guy?
No.
Bra-loha!
Wait, this place is huge and there's only one teleporter?
Okay.
It's way bigger than it looks on the map.
There's only one fast travel thing?
Kinda crazy.
Wait, there's two?
Where's the other one?
Oh, up there!
Up there!
what is happening over here I found like a breeding ground
wait there's like it's an actual breed what is happening
here what wait why is all this stuff here what is happening
and dungeon is probably if this area is so low level though
this is probably pretty low level oh my bad yeah it's okay I
think They don't want anything to do with me.
They're nervous.
You can find random nests in the world.
This is my first one.
How exciting.
Wait, where'd the guy go?
Uh, I know it's...
Oh, it's not, Clovey.
Wait.
Oh, is it you?
Oh, my God.
I'm going to throw up.
Gosh, dang it.
I don't want another single one of you guys ever again.
I'm sick of looking at you.
Oh.
Oh, come on.
And I know they come in gold.
I don't want them.
Dum dum.
Yeah!
Wait, but they had the Clovey that had like a special...
Oh, they all migrated over there.
We got the Dum Dum bounty.
But they give you oils for polymers.
Ugh.
Look, oh, cute!
Look at all!
There's a ton of these guys.
This would be like a absolute gold mine and if I didn't
already have like a full thing for them.
Alright, so we got him.
I got Mr. Dum Dum.
Let's go this way.
Hi, boss.
Hello!
If you don't want them, why do you keep catching them?
For the supplies!
It's all about the supplies.
Who is down here?
Emergency rations.
Okay, well.
I didn't say that.
Did I go over to that one before?
I'm not sure.
Uh-huh.
Oh, no.
on open up okay so he's that way but there's i see a uh a
fast travel over here baby car thanks for the five gift in
thank you thank you dummons are good for the meat cleaver
you guys are worse than me
than me.
And we leveled up.
I keep pressing map instead.
Let's see.
I'm going to do more stamina.
Stamina is awesome to have.
We got technology stuff.
Compound bow.
Wait.
Production assembly line.
Okay, let's get some of these.
Reinforced arrows.
Electric cooler.
What?
Dragon grenade.
What the heck are these?
Alpha wave generator.
We've...
like have we've i i feel like in game i'm supposed to be
past like the industrial revolution and i'm i'm not there
you know what i mean like the game is like look at all this
technology and i'm like me hit how with sword eggy is the
only one with unique name no also also meow cat
Oh, are you our boss?
Oh, it is!
Okay.
Nightwing.
Alright, come on.
Let's get this over with.
Oh.
Well, that?
Was easy.
Sometimes Ungabunga is the strongest tech.
I'm old school.
Eggie.
Eggie, no!
Eggie!
I was supposed to catch him!
Alright.
Let's fast travel to home, drop off some stuff, and then
we'll go do the quest.
Eggie needs mercy.
All of my guys need mercy.
Actually, no.
Then who would...
Then who would kill?
Yeah, we can go get our torrentress, too.
So true.
The temptation to go get that fast point, fast travel, is
like, driving me insane but it's oh it's even in a dark part
of my oh my gosh it's so tempting also wait no it's fine if
I don't do that one not yet at least okay I think I did it
though because I think I came down here and then went around
I think I got it alright let's go back home yeah maybe we
add surgery to egg yeah Meow cat I feel like is pretty good
about like Is there a reason why you don't fly?
Because I...
Why is everybody so obsessed with me flying?
I just prefer being on the ground and exploring on the
ground.
Everybody wants me to fly.
I feel like a...
Like a Disney character being like...
No, father.
I just want to use my legs.
They're like, no.
Everybody flies around here.
You're embarrassing me.
I'm like, no, father.
raises carrying capacity.
Oh.
I didn't even notice I had that.
We want to see you soar to great heights.
I mean, maybe one day I will.
But for now...
Why?
Oh.
We can combine the dog coins.
I think it's fine.
I'm going to get rid of the shotgun.
This is...
Fine for now.
I just started playing a few days ago and got addicted to so
much base management.
I've gotten vastly over-leveled.
Oh, nice!
That's the thing is, I never really care about the base
management stuff in this game.
I'm all about...
Oh, we can make one.
The exploration and all.
favorite stuff okay wait they're back oh wait i think maybe
i have to greet them home hmm
whoa we got some pork let's go okay she's exploring i do be
exploring
mushroom food pork is it cooked or
No, oh, okay.
Whoa, we can make some marinated mushroom.
Let's make that.
Co-starring Jack Black as the talking dodo bird who's like,
I wish I could fly.
And the other girls taking care of the base management
aspect of it didn't help.
Yeah, right, I feel like, I mean, I could learn now.
it's like you know if I'm if I'm carried a little bit that
I'm like oh I didn't I didn't learn I just didn't learn
she'll never learn you guys she'll never learn
let's make some mmm make us on pork Jack black you say work
Jack black you say I am a passenger princess and I'm proud
Powell world princess Powell Wassenger princess yay play it
your way that's what I've been doing I mean I am still
making things I've upgraded our base at least so our base
isn't the prettiest base maybe but I say it's pretty
sufficient.
Alright, let's do this one since it expires more quickly.
Okay.
Oh, actually, well, no, it's okay.
Wow, look at all these!
Are we finding it?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
um i don't remember where i had there we go that's exactly
where i had i built mine on the ocean this morning
um there were things that we were trying to get was it armor
hold
on let's see what things i do have okay so i do i did
upgrade the glider uh there were things that we were i maybe
it was like the better pickaxes and things maybe?
That's the QWERTY!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
We can get the compound bowl which then means we could do
the refined... Oh, that's a spear.
Where's a...
Where's our arrows?
Heat resistant metal armor.
Yeah, we need to get that eventually, don't we?
Where's the arrow?
arrows in it.
We got this one, the V1 armor.
I'm not sure if it was worth it.
Top row.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, I can make these too if I get the... I mean, I've been
so, like, loving my sword, but I don't use it all the time.
I think this is worth making.
I think making the compound bow and getting some arrows on
it is pretty good.
Mmm.
I don't like the look of the V1 armor, but it feels strong,
you know?
Going to bed, good night, mean, don't go.
Bowl will be good for flying pals.
Yeah, I still use mine sometimes, so I think it's good to
have.
All right, and we'll make...
I don't know.
We can make...
Well, I don't want to use all the carbon fiber.
We'll make like...
No, I think it's fine.
We still have...
have so many arrows i mean it's not as good but oh the
saddle for the spider lady yes thank you thank you let's see
uh that would be over this way yes yes make more this one
saddle for spider lady nice we have enough work work there
we go yeah the tarantra saddle oh Oh, but I like egg-y.
Help me.
Carbon fiber is easy to make in bulk.
Phoebe, Chan, Cheeby!
Thank you for the red.
Hello, Phoebe.
Hello, hello.
Hi.
Oh, Phoebe.
What were you doing?
You were the...
Oh.
You were doing the Choicer Voicer, no?
That's in Glitchway, thank you!
Hope you have fun.
I was playing Choicer Voicer.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I'm playing Powell World.
I am once again playing Powell World.
All right, let's get her.
Thanks for the read.
I hope you had fun.
Choicer Voicer was so fun when I played it before, too.
Wait, where'd my, where'd Eggie go?
Okay, Eggie, I'm putting you, like, right here, so I know
where you are.
Wait, I'm so excited.
Let me, let me get on you.
Let me get on you.
Oh, like, we're, oh, I was going to say we're so slow,
but...
Spider, spider, spider, spider, spider, spider, spider.
spitter spitter spitter spitter spitter spitter spitter
spitter spitter spitter does
she have a uh oh my gosh she's so cute look at her oh my god
use the web
oh my god spider-man Spitter, spitter, spitter.
Yeah!
She only has six legs, so she isn't an arachnid.
Shh.
Actually, oh, well, yeah.
I guess it'd be counter arms, right?
This is imaginary world, and arachnids only have six legs.
Free grapple!
Wait, that's so awesome!
Okay.
Oh my god, so cute.
I kind of...
I love the...
Tarentress?
I kind of want Eggie for the...
for uh what's it called the volcano though i feel like
because he can jump very high just one of my two weeks at
work because i landed my dream job i've been applying to
this brand for 10 years and things finally fell into place
oh my god tompkins congratulations congratulations that's so
awesome That's so awesome!
I decided I'm going to bring her anyway.
Let's go to here, the base.
And we then head our way up.
There was even a...
Some sort of quest up here, but I think we're still a little
low level for it, unfortunately.
Yeah, well...
Oh, geez, I forgot this is where it put us at.
Do I go this way?
in south.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, maybe I'm going back home.
We're gonna make the the heat.
Yeah, we're gonna make the heat armor instead.
Yeah, we were just on fire.
Don't worry about it.
I don't want to have chill it out the entire time.
I mean, I know I could, but it'd be easier just in case I
need to switch to another pal.
I don't want to keep taking heat damage.
Alright, let's see.
Oh no.
What do I need?
Ingetts.
Just regular Ingetts?
Just regular Ingetts.
Cancel.
Ingetts, please.
Ingetts.
please like 50 of them start many many many many many many
many many many many many many ingots chile is also
vulnerable to heat i think it's just it wouldn't be wise to
go in if i didn't have a plan oh we can also put away my old
oh wait we can equip i didn't actually equip this i just
made it so we have that now and i can put my old one in here
Um, very good.
Yes.
Miss Vituber's on fire!
How many did I need?
60.
Oh, I don't think I made enough, actually.
Yeah, I only made 50.
I'm a dummy dumb.
Uh, I need more.
Whoa.
I'm a dummy dumb.
Uh, more?
More.
more
just just make up we'll have extra then you can't use the
old arrows with the compound there wait okay wait I can oh
oh how do I make the carbon fiber was that red armor in
storage it shouldn't have been Only the reinforced ones.
It's a schematic.
Pretty sure it's the one we're making, so...
How do I make the cart...
Charcoal and fire organs.
Might need to be unlocked, but how did I...
Make it before then.
How did I get it before?
I'll just...
Oh, whoops.
I'm just gonna work on this for now, so we'll at least have
it.
Hmm.
Nah.
Oh, yeah!
Wait, we're getting 200!
I forgot.
Oh, well, we can stop at 100 then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If arrows are times 10.
Or like 150.
We'll go to 150.
Need lots of organs, or at least one organ farmer.
How do I assign somebody as an organ farmer?
That's kind of a terrifying task to have.
Cancel.
Cancel!
Cancel the project!
Organ donor.
Are you watching KR Myth when it drops?
What is that?
I don't know what it is.
um throw these back in here i don't know where and throw
these in here okay now we should be good oh wait new common
rider oh wait i look it up i didn't hear oh my gosh wait i
didn't hear about it
uh Minerider myth.
I'm so behind on Zets though.
I'm so behind on Zets.
My schedule.
I can't.
I don't have time.
Let's see.
Whoa!
Oh my god, the suit is crazy!
What?
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
think it's going to be subbed in english like zets maybe the
thing is is like i'll be able to keep up for like you know a
couple weeks and then oh my god he looks so good yeah the
suit is super clean what the heck i'm able to keep up for a
few weeks and then as soon as it's like uh you know i go out
of town or something for a week or something then else piles
up and it's like oh i'm like ah no
stop i want to stop showing me ads uh
cool wait when does it premiere september 6th that's like in
two days what the heck that's crazy so like tomorrow night
my time whoa oh the suit is nice is nice.
Alright.
So we were making something else with the regular ingots.
Oh, we were making da-da-da-da-da.
We were making this fire resistance.
I think right now, I can't remember what I'm wearing.
I know.
I think it's the cold resistance.
Yeah.
But we'll make the fire resistance now.
cheese okay oh this is gonna take a minute
how is the game going for you so far pretty good pretty good
always need the best furnace you can to make the next ingots
yeah yeah
this series is zodiac count i'm gonna look hold on i'm
trying to like look more into it but it's not tell it's wait
Oh yeah, the tagline for the series is the 12 zodiacs that
never cross paths.
Now it begins.
The common writer myth.
Whoa!
Interesting.
Interesting, interesting.
Exiles doing the...
Exile group rampage is doing the opening song.
Wait, so who is...
Oh, does he like...
Does his suit transform based on the...
Zodiac animal?
Oh my god.
Freaking fandom.com is impossible to use sometimes.
Hmm.
Pineapple, please stop asking strange questions.
Or I might have to time you out.
It's, yeah, it's so full of ads.
I'm just trying to, like, look at anything.
And it's, like, video?
Video?
Last time we went to the volcano, it was so...
I got my butt wiped.
It was crazy.
Mmm.
Anti-Fandom.
What's that?
If I open more than two fandom tabs, it starts to lag my
browser.
That's so bad.
Definitely catch up on Zets when you have time.
You love the mid-season cliffhanger.
Really?
Oh.
I'm so, so behind.
though that's okay one of these days like especially when i
go on like a japan flight or something i get so into wanting
to watch the movies on the plane because i don't go to the
movie theater and they always add like new movies that i
want to see on the plane but one of these days i gotta like
you know download the episode so that i can have them while
i am uh while i'm on the flight I just always forget.
Phantom's only usable with a blocker.
Unfortunately, I don't, I don't, I haven't set one up yet on
my phone.
Okay, hey, we are ready.
Thank you guys, thank you very much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Huh.
Whoa, wait, did I get a tan?
Oh my gosh, it makes me look so much pinker.
I look so pink.
Alright, cool.
Fun fact, the myth in Common Rider myth is actually
pronounced as mice.
And the new main rider is mouse the end.
Wait, really?
So, wait, but I thought it...
I get what?
Oh, no, wait.
I thought it was a rat in the zodiac.
Like it, because it's pink.
Oh.
That's a funny way to...
I guess I kind of get it.
What was it?
Minky Mouse.
We're going back to...
The...
Arcade.
Common Rider Nazarin.
I hear you on the Inflame Movies.
I watched a Minecraft.
movie on my most recent flight.
I can now say that that is the movie I have seen, the most
movie I have seen.
That's where I watched it too.
Most of the time, I watch like all of my movies on...
I think we can go that way.
I watch like all of my movies on um...
On the plane.
I watched sinners recently because you guys recommended it.
And, um, I like, oh gosh, oh, this guy's 38, but we're not
gonna fight him right now.
Um, at first I was, it was kind of slow, and I was a little
like, what's going on?
But I really liked it, I really liked it.
Cenders was so good in IMAX.
Okay, so let's see where we're headed.
Is there, there must be some sort of pathway to follow.
We'll just keep going this way.
I would have enjoyed the sinners more as a series.
Oh, I can see what you mean.
We're trying to avoid these guys because they scare me.
So let's...
We're running for it.
We're running.
We're...
What is this?
We're fine.
Just keep going.
Oh my god.
Chill it, I think we're stuck.
Chill it, chill it, buddy, we're stuck.
Chill it, chill it, I need you to climb.
Chill it, I need you to climb right now.
Chill it.
Climb!
I'll do it myself.
Chill it!
Ignore that guy.
Anyway.
Oh my gosh.
They're not coming after me, are they?
Oh shoot.
Oh no, no, no, no, no!
I'm almost dead!
Oh no, I'm not.
They took my shield out.
Oh my god, please no god, please, god, no.
We're fine!
We made it!
Oh my god!
Screw you, Muldron!
He's gonna kill me.
Can he...
No!
How the hell am I gonna get my stomach?
I need a flyer.
Everybody who has been wanting me to use a flying pal.
Your time has come!
Guys don't look at me, I'm naked.
They all see me spawn in, naked and afraid.
Shivering.
Okay.
Where's that night guy just...
Oh no, I didn't catch him.
He was dead.
Who's somebody that I can ride?
spooter climb I lost my spooter
Vanworm works I think I might have made a let's see I might
have a saddle oh let's see Vanworm there we go awesome let's
go make a saddle how embarrassing no what do i need ingots
it's always ingots i need ingots
oh we have no ore how do i make it so that this guy okay
hold on because we have him whoops it's not what uh no uh
there we go see i want him only on the wait could i put him
on both the primitive and the improved there we go okay okay
Oh no, I can't.
Oh, I wish I could do both.
That's so lame.
We'll give up, we'll put this guy.
I don't think we have any eggs anyway, so he can leave that
spot.
Hmm.
Yes, make ingots.
It is on...
Where are the ingots being made?
Oh, here.
Alright.
I thought we had someone on the orpit.
Oh, is it more?
Oops, I'm too away.
There we go.
It's fine.
We just, this is, this is out of necessity.
You'll need to pick your stuff up quickly or the heat alone
will cook you.
Never mind the enemies.
Yeah, I'm nervous.
How am I supposed to get by?
This guy, how could he see me from so far?
He's absolutely busted.
His target, his attack, like, will literally go through
walls, up mountains.
How does he do that?
It's so unfair.
Okay.
Oh.
That's why I was trying to avoid him.
All right.
Let's give this a shot.
Wait, what do you mean locked?
Oh, I forgot to pick it up.
That's why.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh.
Come here, come here.
Oh, he makes me hot!
Oh, I'm gonna die with this guy.
I'm gonna die for real.
It's fine.
This is a timed battle, everybody.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait, I'm stupid.
I think I need to I need to teleport there.
I'm stupid.
I'm dumb.
Oh.
My bed.
Don't burn my camp, please.
Okay.
Come here.
I was so ready to fly there that I just started going.
Yeah, he's pretty slow.
Okay.
Yeah, I am still on the sloppy server.
Where's my stuff?
How far did I...
Oh my god.
There's my stuff!
Come on.
Oh my god, I'm dying.
I think we'll make it.
Oh my god.
Intense heat.
I'm dying.
My stuff.
Everything is bad.
This is...
Oh my stamina is so low.
This is quite possibly the worst.
Yes!
Grab my stuff!
Oh my god.
Grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it.
Grab it.
Take it all.
Take it all!
Yes!
Pick it up!
Yeah!
Who did we not... Who did we not grab?
Oh, Chillit!
What?
Wait, where's Chillit?
I guess... Oh, go away.
Thank you.
Okay.
The guy's not aggroed, so maybe I'm fine to keep climbing.
What a mess.
In my box, yeah.
Okay, Chilli went to the box.
My, what?
The worst, the worst, pal that could be put in the box in
this situation, but sure.
This is fine.
Am I going to make this?
Maybe.
Probably.
Yep.
She said, yeah.
We're going to make it.
Oh, thank you guys for the gifting.
Thank you.
Wait, did somebody raid me or something?
If so, thank you very much.
I was trying not to die, but I appreciate it.
All right.
Nice.
Where am I going up there?
I might be going an unconventional route, everybody.
We may be going an unconventional route.
I think Tarantris is not the right pal.
for this either though unless oh wait oh
my god
volcanic cavern okay i need to survive first i need to okay
i can't see anything
see this she's good until then you know oh okay hold on i
can't see anything her her ass is bet not a complaint just a
comment not complaining just commenting just making a
comment I might be am I what is the expected way here I
think I'm way off course you guys was it you can double jump
after oh if only I could see if only I could see fly up oh
how oh so stupid oh rise is space okay
there are no stupid questions everybody if I say stupid
question you say there There are no stupid questions!
Minto!
Alright, now...
dismount.
Or gain my stamina?
Or his or whatever, whoever's?
Again.
Rise.
Wait, why am I already at like half stamina?
What just happened?
Rise.
They don't regain stamina in the balls.
Oh, okay, good to know.
Rise.
Wow, look at the sky.
You guys were, like, literally going into space right now or
something.
This is crazy.
Whoa.
Are you okay, Van Worm?
He's like, yeah.
I haven't been out of that box in years.
He's never, he hasn't been able to fly for so long.
I have no idea what's over this mountain.
Whoa!
Descend, descend, descend, descend, descend.
We made it!
I was prepared to climb the entire thing, you guys.
I really was.
Oh.
Oh, it feels so good.
Screw you, volcano.
Screw you.
It's beautiful here, though.
I'm surprised you didn't.
That's fine for now.
Brothers of the Eternal Pire Tower.
Um, do we have this, or...
Uh, am I...
Do you guys think I got this?
This was the next boss, yeah.
Yeah?
Oh, no, let's go get Chillit!
Yeah, let's go get Chillit.
Meowcat is OP.
I agree.
OP in cuteness.
OP in awesomeness.
Oh, it feels so good to be here.
Gonna build a base here to replace Matas' outside base.
I... um...
Don't you have to have like a... you have to have something
unlocked to make something and...
Oh, I went to the wrong one, my bad.
Uh, to make something and base, don't you?
Every base needs a lava pit.
What if we build like a whole thing like a, you know?
Like a platform.
Chill it?
Oh, there you are.
Okay, thank you, Van Worm.
Your job is done.
Your job is completed.
To sacrifice Chilodon to now!
We could have it on top.
I mean, we could leave one hole for sacrificial purposes to
appease the gods.
You know, like if we build a whole thing, like just a
platform all around here, and actually build on top of the
volcano.
Kalima Kalima Wait, there's guys here.
Piran.
Wait, there's so... Oh, it's a whole nest!
Wow, wow, cool.
Kalima.
Alright.
I think Eggie and, like, chill it.
I'm going to send out Eggie, but I think we can do this.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go!
Oh, I'm nervous!
Let's go beat this guy.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
It'd be cool, but the boss tower might be too close.
He can't build near certain structures.
Ah.
Don't zoom in on your boobs.
Whoa.
What are these sound effects?
Oh, whoa.
All right, Eggie, let's kill him.
Oh, wait, he's electric?
Wait.
Oh, he's not.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, he's not.
Ah!
Wait, what do you mean I'm hungry?
Oh, because I have no food.
Go, Lars, go!
And I will also...
Oh,
my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
Dodge, dodge, dodge, dodge.
Okay, um, let's prepare next pal.
Meowcat.
Ow!
Oh, yeah, let's go, Meowcat.
Oh, shoot.
Meowcat!
I think Eggie will be good for this, but...
Oh, my gosh.
Meowcat, no!
Meowcat, don't take damage.
You make me so sad when you do.
Meowcat, stop taking damage.
make me really sad.
Meowcat, no.
The music's fine in this.
Okay, Meowcat, I won't let you...
I won't spread your ashes to the...
to the sea.
To the heartless sea.
Ooh.
Eggies, Eggies tankin' it?
Eggies tankin' it?
No, Meowcat didn't die!
I took him out before he...
Oh, no, he did die!
What?
When did he die?
Meowcat, no!
When did you die?
When did you...
Ow!
When did this happen?
Oh, no, I'm trapped in here with him.
Or he's trapped in here with me.
Oh, Eggie!
Why are you so stupid?
Eggie, don't do that.
Eggie.
I think we've got this, though, guys.
Oh, shoot!
I think we've got... Oh, oh.
Ah!
Yes!
Death, death!
Oh yeah, drag his body around with their mouth.
It's the key sphere of sloth.
I learned crystal...
Oh no, you learned crystal breath.
First try!
That was so easy.
I just killed a man.
And I, do it again.
Oh.
They just send you up here and don't really tell you why,
huh?
They're like, yep, welcome to the top.
It wasn't that neat.
You did it.
Gosh, down there is an actual hellscape, though.
He's making my tummy funny.
Oh.
Just for the nice view.
Report to the client.
That's right, because...
And there's more stuff in here.
There's even another midpoint.
I guess maybe going up this way would have been the easiest,
perhaps.
Maybe I should have gone from down here.
Phantom Ayo!
I know where we're gonna go.
South is easy.
Oh, down here.
Oh, I guess...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, no.
I...
From here?
Oh, it does seem kind of short.
New home.
We could...
Unfortunately...
Maybe this is the closest, and then we go here, hit this
waypoint, and go...
we must report back to the client eventually i guess we
actually we could do that because it's a fast travel is
right there
we're heading to phantom aisle baby well not yet in a second
we're gonna do the game a little bit my favorite palace on
phantom aisle then we'll go then we'll go
I'm gonna feel right at home.
I forgot how noisy this place is.
It would actually drive me insane.
So you took down Axel.
I knew you had it in you.
It would probably take a while for those flames to actually
die out.
But at least they won't be burning so high.
Actually, he was electric, so you freaking lied to me.
That was...
That bout was legit.
That's a whole town or town?
Oh, town or tower.
down my dude you're gonna be the talk of the town now the
mood here will be easy everyone feeling breezy huh why did I
wrap that is it contagious yay fine search for clues about
the next tower
everybody's so noisy here that
way is the next but I don't see it on the map
oh all the way over there wow okay um we're not doing that
oh i forgot again
it's from the animation yeah the them playing the arcade but
it literally resonates through the entire town like they're
so noisy oh let's go heal our pals too sadly we had some
losses including meow cat and i'm very sad about that i'm
very very sad about that meow cat and lunaris you did you
fought valiantly you guys heal up heal up instead we'll
bring um fox sparks and we'll bring
we'll bring van worm you were very loyal And you were good.
Thank you for your service.
Um.
All the way here.
Kelpsey.
What's that snake?
Yeah, they'll be back in 10 minutes.
They'll come back.
We'll be fine.
Yes.
I'm excited to see what's on this island.
So we need to head this way, west, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, so we're going to head to this area.
Seems a little...
Could be...
Oh, why were we gliding like that?
Hmm.
We'll see.
Could be fine.
Probably fine.
Alright, chill it.
You're going to make it all the way over there, right?
We'll aim for this island right here.
Or this beach right here.
Could be lagging a little bit.
It's fine.
Okay, I think we'll make it.
I think we'll make it.
And we can head up this tower here.
Nice.
Now we gotta have Meowcat all healed up exactly, but I don't
know.
I don't think it'll take us 10 minutes to get over there,
so...
Hmm.
We'll see, we'll see.
Okay.
It's a good thing we came to this one instead.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
This is fine.
Let's loot.
Moving, grooving, schmoozing.
Uh-huh.
I need you.
Ha-ya!
Yeah!
Having no stamina doesn't make you down anyway.
It only slows you down.
Yeah, on the...
things no wait what is the ring of trust when an inventory
unlocks recipe for ring of trust epic what is the ring of
trust wait i thought you did drown with without stamina
oh in the water chill it will die without stamina oh then
that's bad oh you take damage slowly i still don't really
want to do that.
Ideally, I would like to not do that, you know?
Ruined Fortress City.
I think we could go around, though.
Oh.
Yeah.
I think we can go around.
Whoa.
Turned blue.
Alright, this should be the area.
Let's Let's ride Eggie.
What's around here, huh?
Let's just go win them.
Whoa, what are you?
Oh, it's the Wixen.
Don't mind me.
You've got Dasher and Prancer and Donner and Wixen.
Comet and Cupid.
Donner and Wixen.
What's up here?
What do you recall?
The most famous...
Oh, dang it.
Dear of all.
Eggie, my jumping deer.
Oh, is this guy going to attack me?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Get off me.
Yeah, go kill him.
Oh, shh.
Ouch, stop hitting me!
Oh my gosh.
I'm on fire.
Yeah, take out that guy.
And I'll take out this guy.
Oh, damn, she's high.
Eggie, I'm helping out!
She can't- she can't shoot me from such a close range.
Stop shooting, my dear!
Am I doing any damage there?
Oh, like the tiniest bit.
Yeah, Eggie, trust me.
Trust me, Eggie.
She can't even attack.
Oh god.
She's doing...
I'm almost at it.
Ah!
Yeah, killer.
It's okay.
We don't need to.
We don't need to catch her.
Or maybe I should have.
We could go back.
Oh, I thought that was your stuff.
More stamina.
Nice.
Pizza.
Yippee!
my gosh a pizza made by piling red berries tomato and cheese
oh what but you both like pineapple on your pizza how could
you attack yeah we were brethren we were we were sisters
we're sisters eggie you deserve that and me too wait oh gosh
this is gonna expire uh chalet you can eat that there we go
all right nice well we killed that that that person uh the
northish can we make this oh egg is awesome egg is too good
the pitzer the best pitzer in all wait uggy why why is your
health is it because you're healing why is your health
flashing the best pizza in all of London where is this thing
oh I'm going the exact wrong way I'm oh wait it's not north
I'm a big old dummy dumb
starving no definitely not I just fed I've fed egg he got
the pizza up here oh oh oh nice okay we found least it's see
it's almost like flying when I'm with Eggie it's great no
okay and over there probably no over here probably who is
our whoa what is that what the hell that's what you expect
me knock them you Yeah, because he's gonna knock him out, my
teeth!
What the hell?
This guy's ginormous!
Oh, whoa!
I would say he's our goal for today, but I don't think...
Where'd he go?
Into the wall?
Wait, how did he do that?
He's a wizard.
55.
Yeah, I think that will have to be...
Oh, what?
Oh, Bushi!
Look how cute you are.
I think that is, uh, that is a little bit of a longer term
goal for, uh, yeah, it's quite the gap, unfortunately, at
the moment.
Let's check this place out, though.
First.
Let's see if we can do this dungeon.
it's a little gitty but I think we can do it let's go oh no
yes I think we can do it we can manage this one I think we
can maybe chill it we'll carry that's exactly who I think
we're gonna do gitty gitty oh no it's one of these dungeons
I wish it was just one of the like brothers of the eternal
pie martyr get out of here bro come on I don't want to deal
with your stinking this stinky guys wait
is this it oh okay maybe it's not so bad oh never mind it is
bad wait where do we go oh stinky yeah they smell like
sulfur and sadness oh Look, they're just like, what are you
guys even in here for?
What are you doing?
Why are we just laying on the ground?
Yeah, we are not burning to death.
That's really great.
It is.
I have a feeling that's the way I need to go.
For the boss of the dungeon.
But.
Right?
I feel like it.
Oh.
Okay, there we go.
Holy cow.
That was scary.
That was scary for a moment!
How are you guys able to walk on the lava like that?
Oh, I think there's just a chest in here.
I think that's it.
How can she...
Wow, we got a full meal!
Look, they're just sitting down.
They're so boring.
It's fake lava so I can walk in it too.
Ouch!
And now we're on fire!
No!
Ouch!
Stop!
Haven't I had to go through enough, please?
The floor is lava.
That was the definition of getting one guide, I think.
Leave me alone!
Oh, shoot.
Come on, man.
I don't want to deal with you.
Oh.
Ah!
This is not the boss, is it?
Chill it!
Help!
Oh my god.
Wait, is he dead?
Oh, shoot.
Thanks, Chillit.
I almost died.
Holy cow.
Well, Chillit, definitely carried.
Ice is weak to fire.
He's all I have!
Well, I guess I have Eggie too.
Eggie would be pretty good also.
Eggie is also, like, water-ish, I think.
Oh no, don't tell me it's going to be one of these guys.
Say it ain't so.
Wait, where am I?
How do I...
Oh, I need to go over there.
Oh, they're afraid of me.
Aki is normal type, but we have water.
He has water moves.
Maybe I should take care of these guys, though.
Oh.
Come on.
This is evil.
This is absolutely evil.
I need to get rid of my mercy ring sometimes.
Ah!
They're coming at me!
Whoa!
They're coming this way!
Wait, Eggie, no, I need your help.
Eggie, they're coming this way!
Eggie!
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
Wait, was that the boss?
Wait.
Can you come back?
Why did they...
I
guess we'll just wait here until he comes back.
They're eating them.
They're eating the corpses.
What if I get their attention?
A warning shot.
Yeah.
Eggie, no.
Come over here.
No.
I need you to come over here for this.
Okay.
Might be stupid.
Whoa!
Whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop.
Oh, okay.
Now I need Eggie.
But don't kill them.
Nice.
Yeah, see, he does water damage.
He does...
Oh, we!
Oh, come on.
Oh.
No.
Come on.
Please.
Wait.
Biggest fear.
Iggy, come back.
Don't touch me.
I won't let you.
Yay!
Yehoo!
If only we could have captured one more.
We would have had the...
We would have gotten the bonus.
We survived, everybody.
part is though all that matters is we survived yeah yeah we
survived yeah that was silly that was so silly let's leave
whoa i want to take i want to go after that other guy so bad
oh it's i want to go after him so bad the big guy over there
i want to see him in my base because is humongous you know
so it's funny what did we get bellinor slab we tore in the
slab anybody hungry eggy me i'm pretty hungry i'll eat i
could eat such a few months ago i got a kitten named her
minkey she went from less than one pound to 2.2 3.5 and now
She's five pounds.
His little men are super healthy, playful, and cute.
Oh, Jellie Bean.
I'm so happy.
Your little baby's happy and healthy and evil as little
kittens should be.
Yeah.
No logging.
I think we're going the right way.
Yeah.
What is... Oh, that's the...
I was like, I thought it looked like a spaceship from
behind.
That's those evil islands that will kill you real fast.
And you're the evil guy that will also...
Get it, Meggy.
I wonder if I could.
I want to capture him.
Don't touch me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I think we can get him.
Come on.
Yeah.
Oh, that's our first time getting a blaze howl.
Good fire, pal.
That doesn't sleep.
Oh, well there we go.
We got him.
Yes, that was awesome.
I've been wanting to get one of those guys.
That guy kicked my butt one time too, I remember.
We got a schematic for a good.
That's fun.
Let's see.
So we're going to run into this thing.
I'm just going to go in the water, but we're going to stay
because Chilit's so fast in the water, but we're going to
stay along the shore.
Nice.
Yeah, that guy really kicked my butt one.
So we got our revenge and it was sweet.
Oh, we'll grab this thing though first.
Can you see?
CQC?
I learned from the best.
I've only...
I learned CQC from the best, baby.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Scared the heck out of me.
Sorry, Wixen.
You're gonna get your...
You're gonna... You're gonna die for real, though.
Oh!
I didn't mean to use that sphere.
Ah!
Can I not capture that?
Oh!
No!
This is fine.
Is that it?
No.
That's bad.
Alright, chill it.
This is fine.
We're also, like, so close to...
The tree.
We're so close.
Special guardian pal or whatever.
Wait.
No, that's even further in the distance.
I don't know what we just saw then.
Oh, that's that.
Yeah, I have no idea what that is over there.
Interesting.
Very, very interesting.
Hold on.
I think we need to get our stamina back up.
And then we'll head over there.
We'll go full stamina.
Yeah, it's much further than it looks.
Yeah, it's deceiving, huh?
Okay, boss.
This map is ginormous.
Whoa, gross!
Jump scare!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Is that it over there?
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
What the hell is a gangler?
Wait, he's level 54!
Go, go, chill it, go.
Chill it.
We almost didn't make it out of there.
That was terrifying.
The gangler.
I didn't.
Hold on.
I got to get a cough drop or something.
Something for my throat.
I also need to get more.
Whoa!
I need more water.
Whoa.
It's getting spooky.
I didn't record anything today because I wanted to make sure
I rested my throat for a day.
Wait, is that a bunch of ganglers?
Are we in trouble?
Oh, but they're fine.
They're not evil ganglers.
They're just chill ganglers.
He's actually a great swimming pally as an innate swimming
boost that makes him faster.
Ooh, interesting.
Wait, one of them's evil.
Fuck.
Let me capture him!
Ah!
Let me out!
Oh shit.
Ooh.
Just send out anybody.
Oh my god.
I'm so dead.
How dare you?
Oh dang it.
I really didn't.
Oh my god.
I really did want- Oh I don't even know how I sent that guy
out.
Dang it.
Oh I wanted one.
Eggie cleaning house for real.
I did want to try and get one.
Dang it!
My luck was not on my side here.
Um.
I should probably go...
Oh, I'm running out of pals.
Yeah, there's still plenty around.
That's very true.
Let's go home.
For just a brief moment.
Switch everybody out.
Now let's switch everybody out Try to recall your pal When
they're low HP There was just so many That it was like
really tough to do so Because then they would all gang up on
me And it would be not great So We lost Chillit But actually
Chillit got us to the place That we needed to go to So it
all worked out
Okay We go back.
The slaughter.
Eggie cleared.
It was great, though.
And we have Meowcat again.
I'm very happy for that.
Wait, what are you guys?
Gelroys.
Oh.
Some that are upset.
Don't pay any attention to me.
Yes, keep flying that way.
What is that over there?
Special.
No, we'll do Meowcat.
And we'll do Hypersphere.
Oh my god.
Meowcat killed the other two.
Wait, that's kind of perfect.
That's kind of perfect.
Good job, Meowcat.
Come on, come on, come on.
Whoop.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, we got 90 kinds of pals.
Very nice.
All right, yeah, our first one and it's a shiny.
Yippee!
What is this?
Generating electricity, pal.
Oh, don't look at me.
What's up there?
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I'm trying to see.
Oh.
Trying to see what they look like.
Oh, oh, I think the head just went spinning for real.
Whoa!
That got me up new level.
They are fast, aren't they?
Oh, I want one!
We'll do more stamina.
Look at that, we're at 20 stamina.
Awesome.
You have Pallpedia.
but he's right in front of me.
You dang kids, you always got to look at your phones.
I've got a dang good pal right in front of me, and I'm
trying to look at his face.
I don't need no palpedia when the dang pal's right in front
of me.
Yep.
And I'm climbing.
Just like in the olden days.
With my...
You guys have to understand, I love climbing.
Look at my arms.
Oh.
Uh.
Fancy seeing you guys up here.
They really do hang out in like a whole gang.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Well, uh.
Meow cat.
Help out, please.
Oh, my God.
Meow cat is clearing house.
Oh.
Meow cat.
My God.
Leave some for me.
This thing is still trying to attack me from the grave.
Meowcat is a little OP sometimes.
Maybe we don't use Meowcat for these guys.
Maybe we'll use somebody else that will like...
Sorry.
Get off of me.
What else is up here?
There's a chest.
And a lot of rock.
I kind of want...
Whoa!
I want to go into the pirate ship.
Ha!
Now what do I need for this?
I need a pal that can meow and is a cat.
Watering pal.
Peggy's close enough.
Actually, I think Lunaris might be best because both
Tarantris is a meow cat are the same type.
Wolf dog.
you?
Are you mocking me?
Oh my gosh.
Lunaris, don't die on me.
Oh.
It wasn't very high, but whatever.
Holy cow.
Oh, I caught one!
Oh, come on.
There's one other.
Tarantras died already!
Okay, Meowcat, it's all up to you.
Oh my god.
Ah, he died.
Oh my god I'm dying so much this time But we got one No I
should go home But we got one But we got one Yippee Meow
cat's the only one I tried my entire party Ah yeah no risk
no reward exactly Oh
Now we need a whole new team, huh?
Everybody's down.
I'll get them with their own.
This guy...
Wait, this guy is going to be awesome.
On...
Wait.
Hold on.
Uh...
PAL management.
Take out the normal...
Blaze Howl.
And put in...
new got what did i just put in it oh i think i just i think
i just put it muffly on accident sorry muffly need the
saddle though yes we will get one thank you for the reminder
though let's let's just grab some some some tough guys i
guess we and sit around your You're tough, you're tough,
you're tough.
You're tough.
Catava!
Okay, this is our backup team.
Let's go get my stuff.
Hello?
There we go.
Mufflee's time to shine.
Oh, Herbal has a revive!
Wow!
Oh, my god.
Terrifying spawn point.
Ah!
Wait, I think I need to go up this way.
Yeah, just kill him, just kill him.
Not me!
No!
Wait, it's fine.
We'll just respawn in the same spot.
Baby.
I could just grab my pals right over here.
Oh my god.
Please.
Leave me alone.
Oh shit.
29 health in a dream.
Alpha dread?
Are you okay?
In there?
I needed...
I came this way because I wanted to climb this wall is very
not easy to climb huh I was gonna go oh god this is so bad
you guys um oh shoot oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh oh okay um fly up there that's what I'm thinking
that is what I'm thinking who do I have that's a reliable
pal to fly I have a saddle for that one guy but I think I
don't have him anymore unfortunately okay we at least have
chillit and fox sparks they're alive again oh my god this is
this is uh
yeah okay Oh, we do have a backup armor.
Wait, yeah, because I mean, I'm pretty sure I left it here.
Unless I just had it on me.
If so, that's not great, either.
Yeah, it was on my body.
Nightwing might help temporarily.
Wait, is he in here?
Am I blind?
Oh, they're...
Van Worm.
I have level one Van Worm.
Okay.
I have the saddle for him.
I
don't know if I have a saddle for this guy.
He even has one.
Okay.
I'm just gonna take some...
Here.
Can I sort by level?
Oh, no.
It's really that...
the higher.
Oh, okay, here we go.
Never mind, never mind.
It's...
Okay, this guy I'm am arrested.
Okay.
Alright.
The dream team.
Fox Sparks' health is bugging out.
What's wrong with it?
It's going up.
Both of them are going up.
Level one van warb is gonna carry us.
Take me home.
Country roads.
To the place.
I belong.
Oh, Ragai.
You.
Well, we're gonna, we're gonna collect this up here first.
If I'm, if it's possible.
I don't need to.
I don't even know if it's possible.
I'm too scared.
This could be real bad guys.
Already?
Oh my god.
Down.
Run!
What?
Oh geez.
What the hell?
Oh, I made it here.
Everybody's sad.
What's happening?
Oh my god!
What are we attacking?
Van Worm?
I'm saving you from...
From this place.
Oh, I should have grabbed some armor, baby.
It's fine.
Herbal can revive you if you die.
Does he just need to be in my inventory?
Look at all my stuff.
This island was a mistake!
We don't wonder it's called Phantom Island!
It's because everybody's dead!
It's because I- Oh shoot.
It's because I just died!
I don't know how to get my stuff, you guys.
I don't know how to do it.
Maybe these guys will be kinder.
Run.
Grab.
Stop.
Get my stuff, please!
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Oh my god.
It's because the jelly guys are not as aggroed.
Oh!
Ah!
Sorry.
Get me the hell out of here.
I'm gonna go teleport from what about the B team we're
working on it we're working on it we just had to get out of
that situation we had to get out of that situation
I don't maybe the back maybe hmm okay hold on I know there's
some guys over here which we will want to avoid so I'm gonna
swoop around extraction shooter island.
We're going to swoop.
We're going to make a big we're going to go from the back.
Where is everybody?
Okay.
That makes me more nervous.
Okay, there are some guys on the shore.
Okay.
We're swooping around.
I'm stressed.
But at least some of my team has made it back to the box
because I was able to pick them up.
Coast seems clear.
We're gonna have...
Oh, we have...
Okay.
We're gonna have Lee's nuts on standby.
Just in case things go wrong.
Just in case things go very wrong.
Alright.
I'm sneaking.
Okay.
I think the coast is clear, but can't be too sure.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, everything retrieved.
We are good.
But we're not in the clear yet, guys.
What is that shiny right there?
What's this shiny?
Oh, just some leather.
Okay.
Bam worm?
I kind of want to go fishing.
No, no, no.
Wait, there's something out there even too.
Oh my gosh, I haven't even experienced that yet.
Mission complete.
Not yet, not yet.
This island is a little...
It's doable, but it's tough, you know, for me.
Because there's two groups of aggressive guys so it's doable
but it's tough yeah back up oh gosh it's these ganglers they
really do gangle up on you I hate it they're scary yeah
there's a lot of do yeah doable but deadly I want to explore
the inside real bad gosh please don't notice me please don't
notice me Okay.
Alright, once we get over here, we're out of here.
Oh, jeez.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
They're aggroed on something else.
This is good.
This might be...
This is my chance.
I'm just gonna run for it now.
Woo!
Mission complete!
Dum dum dum dum dum dum Dum dum dum Oh You Wait, he's level
40 though I'm gonna add him to my team Welcome to the team,
Gangler Oh Meow cat Jelroy's cute too Violin party increases
items obtained from salvaging by 65% While Jelliet and
Jell-Roy are in your base, Jell-Roy's watering speed
increases by 60%.
A surprise!
Thank you for the time!
Get there!
What is a Jelliet, though?
I don't think I have a Jelliet.
Eggie, welcome back!
This van- uh, this- one of the van worms I have to return to
the other base.
Um, sort by level?
Sort?
Um...
We're waiting on Tarantris and Lunaris, I guess.
Jelly donut.
Yeah.
Jellyette is a cutie?
Wait, where can I find Jellyette?
Jelly's one of the better watering pals if you invest.
Who's our watering people right now?
We've got Serpent.
What's Jellaroor?
Three also.
three but a shiny you can fish her and oh no oh no you have
to fish her oh yeah I'm glad meow cat's back too doable but
deadly is how Acelot describes snake
I wonder if I have jelly yet
oh my
anyway um we'll grab chill it for now and why not you know
new pal new pal no we'll do fox parks actually but chelroy
looks so good in our party you know well now we'll do fox
parks um
let's go this way we have not really explored like any of
this I will change my armor
and we'll put stuff away.
Yes.
We'll feed.
I'm probably hungry.
Everyone's hungry.
Oh, I can put on this ring too.
Wait, what does it do again?
Oh, no, I just have the schematic.
That's right.
Ring of trust.
Wait, can I make it in here.
Delroy has your ghost leaves too?
Really?
I'll have to see.
Wait.
Okay, fine.
I'll do the powpedia.
Is there a search?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, so cute!
You're right!
So, so cute!
Oh my god, Wait, wait.
Is this what you guys meant that this looks like me?
Wait a second.
That...
It even has my little fang!
Yes!
This is me!
Looks like a minkey.
Yeah, the fang and the sleeves!
And my hair today is kind of the same too?
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Okay, never mind.
Sorry, Foxbarks.
I don't want to play with you anymore.
My shiny Gelroy.
Hello.
Where are you going?
What are you doing?
Wait, why do you look so unhappy doing it?
Let's see, our ring, our ring, our ring, ring, ring.
The ring of trust.
We need ancient lava.
It just makes it easier to increase your trust.
Where the heck do I get ancient lava from?
Wildlife Sanctuary 2.
Interesting.
Oh, oops.
Oh, my bad.
open sesame insert things i'm gonna leave this bad boy just
in case just in case
um yeah just in case something goes awry nothing should
nothing should I feel though having Tarantris is pretty nice
because I don't need the grapple good if I have her Oh she's
back to normal
And so is Lunaris
Hmm Um Hmm There's a fire just your pal later on That looks
like you basically murdered its entire bloodline Anytime you
asked it to build Wait, that looks like you basically
murdered its entire bloodline anytime you ask it to build
any structure.
What the heck?
That is true.
Tarantris, I guess, can't... She's... She's fine, but she...
Yeah, she's not great for combat, maybe.
I want to... We'll try Gangler and Jelroy.
Make Gangler Saddle.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I want to see it.
make gangler saddle ride into water into the sanctuary mine
the lava and leave with the same method oh it's kind of
genius gangler nice hey yeah yeah yeah can i make it oh i
can i can nice but i'm not gonna go into the thing right now
I don't necessarily feel like I need a ring of trust super
desperately.
Though I would like to go and explore that area.
I honestly want to explore the first area, the first island
a little more.
Why don't we do that?
Why don't we go to the first island, the one that's close to
us?
Because there is a pal on there that I have not seen.
So let's do that instead.
Is there, like, a close-by one?
This is, like, the closest.
Am I the closest?
Oh.
Wait!
Oh, I forgot to grab it.
I forgot to grab it.
I do that every time.
I do it literally every time.
Oopsie!
Well, it's a good thing I brought him out, because otherwise
I would have...
Can I ride on him on land, too?
Where is he?
Holy!
Oh.
Uh.
He's an actual...
He's a real fish, you guys.
This guy's a real fish.
Alright, gangler.
Dive.
Dive, dive, dive!
Does he have no stamina?
Wait, there's...
He can just go forever?
I don't see a stem in the thing.
True water, pal, so no stem.
Oh, I haven't had the joy of experiencing a true pal yet.
Wow.
Okay.
Interesting.
Very, very interesting.
Now, does this dome have those, like, lasers that will kill
you in one shot?
it is salmon oh wait this is this means this is like oh that
answers my question okay that answers my question I only see
the one so let's go in this way
or not
a beach what's up beach okay nice now I'm guessing if there
is one around like a one of the drones I just have to hide
under I just have to hide right I'm guessing that's kind of
the idea
alright so this guy is just straightforward okay this island
is so low now for like for it's so low in terms of level now
compared to us oh oh it's a graze bolt oh
oh shoot i feel like i'm gonna obliterate him with everybody
that i have oh thanks for the raid oh rocky
hello hello i'm playing pow world I hope you had a nice
dream.
Um, we're, I'm just going around.
I'm just doing stuff.
All right, don't kill him.
Oh, be careful.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, whoa, wait!
That was close.
A little more.
It's not very great, but...
Thank you, thank you, Remax.
Thank you, guys.
Wait.
First try!
Let's go, Tarantris!
You did it, my queen.
My queen, my queen.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
what was that oh what a funny glitch oh it's getting dark
out now oh um then i guess we can leave because uh i did
what i came out to do that was pretty easy
oh wait oh i do have this guy i remember him yeah he's fine
oh i thought it was dark outside am i is it a lie it's a lie
okay gangla gotta watch we gotta watch out though i'm scared
i'm scared of the drone i'm scared of the drone and safe
okay Um, uh, um, um, we were going this way!
Um, um, um, what if we go this way and get the teleporter on
that island?
Clean mission, boss.
Yeah, that was really clean, huh?
Uh...
Everything is too big.
Yeah, we could just swim everywhere.
I think that's the island right in front of me.
It's not that far.
Somewhere beyond the sea.
Somewhere waiting for me.
My lover stands on my...
My fishy swims throughout the sea.
I don't remember the words I only remembered for...
For me to with love.
What is this thing floating?
We'll meet.
Oh, we'll meet.
Wow, that's evil.
We'll not meet at that place.
Oh, the guys are like loading in and dropping to the sea.
I'll
be sailing Is that the thing up there?
Oh, it's getting dark.
It might be dangerous But I'll risk it for you I know
bring me to you where is this now other side can I cut
through here
how do you say this oh 32 okay okay not so bad not so bad
Okay, okay, not so bad, not so bad.
Not so bad, not so bad, but I still want to go around.
That guy's just doing whatever he wants to do.
Scouring.
Okay, so it is scouring.
Lots of dig choices.
Dig choices who want to kill me.
I finally was able to come to this place.
The place for my dreams.
Okay.
Sandy Hill.
I still haven't been able...
A fishing rod must be equipped.
Wait, I have one of those.
Wait, oh, I had it.
I don't think I've...
Whoa!
Oh, wow, I've never done one of those.
Okay.
Neat.
Very, very neat.
Very cool.
Um...
Now...
Oh, I saw it.
I probably should have gone the other way around.
No, I did not see it.
I'm a liar.
I passed it.
Where is it?
You guys are funny.
Oh god, he's drowning!
Never mind, he's fine.
We go up.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, he's fine, he's fine.
I don't think even Tarantris is good here.
I think it might be not so great.
Mintosis supposes her toeses or roses, but Mintosis supposes
erroneously.
Her mintosis knows her toeses aren't roses as mintosis
supposes her toeses to be.
Well, what?
That was just lovely, dude.
Spiral.
Should I call you M&M spiral?
Oh, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Yep.
Here we go.
Take a break.
Never mind.
Gamers never break.
Uh, maybe this was a mistake.
Uh, come on.
Come on.
One of these ledges.
Like right here.
Really?
This one.
Ouch.
I don't... Oh, I do have my grappling hook.
I didn't have it equipped though.
Oh, what's a better way?
Maybe this one right here.
And we'll have Tarantris just in case.
Yeah, gamers ignore fall damage.
We don't care.
all damage.
Alright, nice.
Yep.
Ooh.
Ha.
Yep.
Woo.
Oh, yeah, this way would have been so much better.
It's, I still, I think, let's see, even if I ride her.
That guy's still drowning.
Oh my god, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Do you need assistance?
Oh, he's fine.
I think my pal is not coming.
Maybe.
Alright, come here.
You bitch.
You sabotaged me!
It wasn't her fault and whose was it?
Oh wait.
Hold on, let's shoot upwards.
Can you jump past the string?
I did.
Hello!
Oh, I'm waiting.
There we go.
Hey!
nice okay they're a little higher level here um oh it's a 40
needle whoa what's the lure on this guy whoa oh my god he's
got he's got loot at his feet ah shit i
wonder we might be able to
Ouch!
Yee!
That hurt.
Oh my gosh.
Where's my...
Oh, there it is.
I probably should try a hypersphere instead.
Okay.
Nice.
Come on!
Oh!
Yeah!
Nice!
Wow!
Somehow we did that!
Joe Roy kicked booty!
That was awesome!
That was great.
Great job.
I think I gotta go up here for the...
Oh shoot.
I have to go up here for the, uh...
Oh, um...
Hmm.
I think we can bake it.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, well, that's not what I meant to do.
And, uh...
Oh, wait.
Is that a spot?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I'm Spider-Man.
Oh, gosh.
I did it, me too.
I went to a really terrible spot.
Oh.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I am Spider-Man!
I wish I could have used my gun there, though.
Would have been a perfect spot, too.
Nice.
What the?
Oh, I see what I'm doing.
Can I drop, actually?
Can I, like, just get back to...
Nope.
Come on.
I was standing here just a second ago.
Please.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Was it here that I was standing?
Where was I standing?
Oh, no.
It's all over.
Wait, we're so close to the top.
We're so close.
I was so close.
I was trying to at least get into the water or something.
um i lost my guy that has infinite swim i don't think we can
make it back there
oh do i have another fish does this guy have him can i ride
the turtle or what if about no he's not an infinite swim
not even through flight i think that's even more unlikely.
Can I ride a flop?
Oh, wait.
What about a kelpsey?
Wait.
If I stay low to the ground, then I don't use the stamina.
Oh, we should be fine then.
If I stay low to the ground...
We'll bring Chilla just in case.
Oh, so far.
Flying works but slow.
Well, we have plenty of time to Zatsu, don't we?
Here we go!
I could just go faster than when it's almost down.
We do the...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there's a chest there.
I never even knew.
Ah.
There we go.
Ah, the...
Oh, this is what you guys want.
wanted you guys wanted me to fly and all that's all you know
what you guys are getting your wish this whole stream aren't
you so aren't you so happy and lucky
the thrill of the flight honestly it's just a nice day oh
there's a there's a thing here probably really low level
though unfortunately
Ah, but the no fly run, I know, I tried to keep it up as
long as I could, as long as I could.
And I would fly 500 miles, and I would fly 500 more, just to
be the bird who flies a million miles to get back to that
shore.
That was beautiful.
Look, we're already, like, halfway there.
Whoa!
You guys know those, like, musicals that are, um...
Jukebox musicals, so it's like...
They like take songs from...
like...
Artists and things.
I looked it up, you can press C to stop climbing on
keyboard.
You can!
I learned something new every day?
What would I do without you guys?
Jukebox.
Shut up!
You know what I mean.
The Jukebox.
the musicals so it'll be like they'll be like don't worry
guys we're already halfway there whoa we're halfway there
whoa oh like uh think glee think glee you know glee is is
that exact way where they like use songs they'll be like um
They're going to be like, yeah, well, I may cry tears for
you right now, but you're going to miss me when I'm gone.
I'm on the mountain on the long way around.
They got mountains, they got them, but they got sides to
give you shivers, but still worry about with you when I'm
gone.
When I'm gone, you're going to miss me when I'm gone.
You know, they'll like have a moment and then use a song
that matches the moment.
Cups!
The cup song!
What are they doing?
They're worshiping it.
All hail the glowing chest.
Like Tomodachi life, that one dream.
Brain sinks to the lyrics.
Boss, you could have been such a beautiful singer.
I could have been.
But look at me.
Ow!
Oh, what's another thing that you could do?
It's like, oh, man.
Nobody, everybody just looks through me.
Like I'm a ghost.
That was a ghost.
I was alone.
Do it in.
It's okay.
Oh!
Oh, this one's so easy.
Yay!
Wait.
Oh, thank goodness.
We have Gangler.
We have Gangler!
Wait.
No, I gotta get back up there.
Wait, I have a bird now.
Aren't you getting the waypoint?
I am now.
I get it.
Ghost plus angler.
I thought he was just oogling it.
Wait, that's an aw-oogler.
I got it.
I got it all wrong.
Googler.
Wait, I want to go over there.
Oh, what?
Oh,
there we go.
I forgot.
I want to try this thing.
No, that's the Googler.
The ghost Googler will come to you.
I didn't know.
All right, Meowcat.
Give me support.
Give me mental support.
You cheated not only the game but yourself.
You didn't grow, you didn't improve, you took a shortcut,
and gained nothing.
You experienced a hollow victory.
Nothing was risked and nothing was gained.
Oh, God.
I'm just, I'm going to end it all.
I'm going to end it all!
Hold on.
Let me get this and then I'll end it.
Oh, I got a hack.
It's this one.
Whoa!
I'm...
I'm insane!
I was talking to the mice!
I was horribly nice, so I had to pay the price!
What's that over there?
Meow cat?
Jump with me.
He runs around like it's such a...
Something's wrong with this guy.
Yeah, honestly, I think the game doesn't want you to...
The game, literally...
Why would they give you the option to climb if all you
needed to do is fly all the time?
I really did... I did...
Oh, shoot.
I'm stuck in the rock.
Never mind, I'm fine.
This is what happens when you cheat and you fly.
Oh my god, it's a whale.
Munchill.
Oh, maybe I should use this to go back home.
I almost clipped into the power rooms.
Wouldn't be the first time.
There's like so nothing up here.
It's kind of sad.
Alright.
Well, guys, I think we're going to call it here.
We, um, I was going to go up and do some stuff up here, but
actually no i'll go another like half hour we'll see if we
can get to that area to that um that mission let's go back
to base we'll go a little bit longer sorry i lied i lied i
lied i am starting to get hungry though what should i have
for dinner Van Worm, thank you for your help.
Because I even got changed.
I got dressed up for our mission over there.
Got a competition.
I'm nervous for tomorrow.
Can you wish me luck real quick?
Wild monkey, you got this!
Good luck, good luck, good luck, good luck.
How's in that area our level 50-ish?
Okay, well.
out of some real um some real binds today so we'll say we'll
say we we will do our best we'll do our best hmm um yeah
this is where we got well we did not get elizabeth that's
right so um Oh my gosh.
Let's just make it to the snowy mountain crossroads.
So that would be east, northeast.
This way.
Northwest.
Yes.
A little more north than west.
I know my directions.
Okay.
Travel.
Climb.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
It sucks when you're falling.
You can't use the web thing, you know?
Oh.
That kind of sucks.
Uh.
There we go.
Look at this.
We're so...
Oh.
Cheating the system.
Wait a second.
Oh, we're fine.
Don't fall, please.
I can't see anything.
I'm taking the risk.
Nope, it didn't work.
Uh, don't go this way.
Everybody, learn from my mistakes.
How do I even get up there?
Oh, I'm supposed to take the...
Okay.
We'll just take the pathway then.
I didn't know it split.
Uh.
Huh.
There we go.
We're learning.
Hey, but I did pretty good the first couple times.
You have to admit.
It was pretty good.
Until it wasn't.
Oh, please.
Oh, yes.
See?
We did it.
And now...
What's that?
I'm so curious.
What are you?
Wait, is this the...
Is this the pal?
That you did.
Thanks.
It's the mimic, yeah.
I don't feel like dealing with his...
With his energy.
Right now.
I'm not in the right headspace.
I'm emotionally wavy.
To deal with...
Yeah!
To deal with that guy.
I saw some bright light.
I'm hungry?
Oh, that's right.
Everybody eat up.
Oh my gosh.
The food is getting devoured.
Oh no, I hope I didn't waste anything.
What are those?
A gorilla rat?
It's a gorilla rat?
It's a gorilla rat.
That's kind of cute.
Oh, it's one of these things.
Okay, beacon.
Wait, all of these are new.
All of this is new to me.
me fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun it's just shadow
he would hate to hear you say that what are we doing we're
hacking uh oh i didn't realize it was one of these easy wow
that was actually the easiest of my life and my afterlife
even an island southwest of the volcano covered in gay
crystals what makes them gay you will find the lover to your
jellyfish thank you i need to go to the gay crystal of
island
what maybe they're rainbow I want to go see what this guy is
So let's head Taurantris is so cute Why is she purr Or chirp
at me
Nice So who is it Oh Another beacon Okay big beacon This is
a cool area I like this Sorry I'm not trying to look at her
butt It just happens Okay Wait, what's the, what's the big
butt called on spiders?
Sounds like an odd TV show.
Next time on Gay Crystal Island.
No way.
The abdomen.
Wait, no.
Oh, is this the... Wait.
Don't kill the messenger of love!
Oh my god!
And they're eating his body!
I can hear the munching.
I'll save you.
It won't let me talk to her anymore.
Are you okay?
Oh, okay.
Okay, she's fine.
Hey there, I'm the messenger of love.
No, emotes.
Oh, it's four.
Hand over.
Thank you.
I'm sorry if you die again, but it's not my problem.
Abdomen would be the tail part on a bug.
I was gonna, it didn't seem right.
Thorax sounds right.
Is it Thorax then?
Why?
These guys are not supposed to be aggressive.
Why'd they go out like that?
Gosh, it really is like...
Oh, evil, evil, evil monkey.
Oh, I can hear the heartbeat.
Why is it evil?
Head thorax abdomen.
Oh, it's the abdomen.
So what is the abdomen?
Okay, let's kill this guy.
Wait, why are we killing that guy?
Um...
Do it?
Oh my god!
Wow!
Hey!
Somebody else after me?
Yay!
We got him.
Nice.
At least I got one before.
Tarantris, are you okay?
Here, I'll send out a...
Meow cat will kill him.
Yeah, good job, Mio cat.
Yeah, push his body away.
We don't care about him.
Nice, nice.
So it's head...
Oh, there's another one?
Why are there so many?
Head, thorax, abdomen.
Meowcat is my greatest fighter.
What level am I?
I'm a spooky level.
44.
Wish I could get my pals up to the same level with me.
Let's travel into the...
I guess we're fine to...
Use Tarantris again.
That's a very spooky level.
La la la.
love going through the woods oh thank you oh oh i was trying
to jump over them base raids drop a good number of exp yeah
but we have to wait for those yeah frostbound i've been
wanting to go to this place for so long now i want that I
think we can get that.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Wait, but that actually kind of worked.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Tarantras!
Nice.
Where are we?
Oh, I'm not even close.
Are we going to see all the...
All the cold pals!
Whoa, there's some cool pals here.
I'm excited to see.
Yeah.
I saw some over here.
Ooh, Rangerex.
Wow.
What are you, bird?
What are you?
Alpha Drunt Aqua.
And we unlocked it.
Unlocked.
Oh.
Where?
It's actually kind of close to me.
Oh, nice.
Wait, how do you know it's aliens?
Was, is that it right there?
Oh, how'd you know it was aliens?
Oh, wait.
Uh, I'm gonna dismount and get rid of you too.
they're only they're small level oh
shoot oh shoot there we go oh shoot maybe i got him yay come
on yay yuppie oh you guys saw nothing
these rocks all these meteorite fragments oh and i leveled
up 45 oh my gosh i'm gonna get my health up a little bit
more all right oh gosh they're so hungry they're so hungry
for human flesh It's kind of insane!
Can you mine the meteor?
You can!
Yeah, just like this.
They're so hungry for humans.
It must be good.
Gotta eat the evidence.
And we were able to take those guys on all by ourselves,
so...
That was pretty nice, honestly.
Not having to like, you know...
I'll wait I'll wait I'll wait there we go come on come on
come on
okay these guys are fine these guys are chill literally
literally chill how do we have a spicy egg up here no body
no crimes except I keep the bodies I let them I make them
work in my in my fields and in my farms and in my mines and
the children yearn for the mines though one moment we are
hacking oh
i mean that was above the law i just you know
i just i just never get caught i just never get and if i get
caught i Literally, I just make them, I also catch them and
force them to be my pals.
Tried to slide in that one, huh?
20, 225 minutes cannibal!
No, it wasn't cannibals, the monkeys were eating monkeys.
Those monkey rats, whatever they were called.
The gorilla rat, the gorilla.
It wasn't me.
I want to know what's in the lake, you know?
Seems very intriguing up there.
Is there an easy way to get up?
Oh.
Okay.
Whoa.
But like what's in here?
There's a special egg!
You said they have to taste good, right?
But you said must taste good.
Well, I'm just assuming because everybody's so hungry for
them.
The monkeys are like, I gotta eat, I gotta eat.
Look at them run.
Real wildlife.
Who needs to go outside when we have all of this?
This is the outside.
This is pal world.
Tell it to the judge.
I'm the judge, jury, and execution.
Whoa, this place is crazy looking.
Oh, it's another...
My mom.
What are you?
You're a little...
Snugglou!
Whoa.
Oh my gosh!
It's a Lenaris effigy!
That's my guy.
Sealed Realm of the Pristine.
What are you?
Sybilix.
Cute.
Oh.
Why are you so mad?
What are you angry about?
Are these guys aggressive?
Even though they're called relaxesauruses, the name is very
misleading.
He can't see his forehead.
Is that why he's so mad?
I can't see my forehead.
That's one.
Uh...
There's another angry, angry guy down there.
Um...
And what's over there?
This also looks like it should be like a...
Wait!
Oh!
Oh, it's already open!
Ring of Ice Resistance!
Let's go!
Yeah, it only needed one and how interesting.
Oh my gosh, I'm making my tummy.
Funny, funny feeling.
Okay, we're gonna get to that sand dunes one, and then we'll
call it, I think.
I can hear him go, doom, doom.
Doom, doom.
I think I spooked that guy.
I get that feeling falling in VR.
Me too, right?
I'm getting the feeling right now.
My tummy.
Oh, hello.
Serpent?
there you go awesome and time yeah vertical stricken oh oh
are you okay i thought i thought the guy was was i thought
the pal was upset are you okay damn it why are those rind
syndicate bastards have to run up there of all places this
game is gonna have kids saying bastard isn't it hey maybe
you can help me some poachers scum stole my best pal I
chased them this far, but then they went and climbed up that
stupid ledge.
I may not look it, but I've got a serious problem with
heights.
I'm begging you.
Get my pal back.
I'll repay you.
I swear.
I wonder if it's up there.
No.
Somewhere else.
Ooh, this area looks evil.
And here we are in a whole new place.
I don't remember what it said it was called.
Um.
But that looks...
delicious give me that chowder and i'm also going to go get
some food thank you guys for pal world today was a roller
coaster of emotions wasn't it my mom really considered that
to be a swear word is it not i think it's a swear word
thanks for piling around today thank you thank you pal world
is so fun
So, um...
Is that... No, that's a waypoint.
Sorry, no, thank you, Owie.
We learned a new type of phantom pain earlier.
Good job, thank you.
Good job taking your stuff back from phantoms, phantom
islands, gaggles and ganglers.
Good job getting your gangler back from the other island.
Thank you for the stream and hope you had a relaxing night.
Thank you, thank you!
You too!
Thank you for being our pal.
Thanks for being my pal.
Wait, wait, oh.
Oh, thank you, me don't thank you.
Make me thank you.
Wait, hold on.
I have a musical, a jukebox musical thing for this.
Thank you for being a friend.
Down the road and back again.
Something, something.
You're a pal and a confidant.
Woo, woo, woo.
Thank you for being a friend.
It's really fun to play this game, but it's more fun when I
have you to tag along.
Yeah, whenever you...
I don't remember how it goes, but if you lose your way and
your pals and you know I'm here your feet oh yeah thank you
for being a friend and a pal and for watching bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye